in a normal world when you do something
that works like making progress on the
border people might say hey dude good
job but this isn't a normal world you
can't have a trade policy based on
tweets I think the president has
completely overblown what he purports to
have achieved I continue to think that
foreign leaders must look at this
presidency in the way we used to look at
particularly unstable regimes
it's a pattern we've seen repeatedly
with this president he he sort of
creates a crisis has some sort of a
fairly general resolution to it that's
lacking any details and then declares
victory yes Vado calling something
overblown that's like the Blasio calling
you unpopular face it if Trump
discovered a cure for death that accuse
him of putting grave diggers out of
business it's weird when someone looks
at something productive and calls it
counterproductive I guess a belt is
counterproductive to keeping your pants
up exercise is counterproductive to
weight loss and border enforcement is
counterproductive to a strong border but
you can't trust people if they can't
even admit obvious results it means that
all the responses are emotional
delusions take me I was a critic of
Trump for a long time and man I hated
tariffs but now I got to admit there's
something to them that I missed and it's
assuring in a new way to solve problems
meanwhile there are people who still see
military solutions as superior to
financial ones when in fact every time
Trump threatens a tariff and means it
maybe that's one less problem solved by
violence Trump wages war with
mathematics not men shouldn't lefties
love that isn't that progress which is
two parts of that word progressive you
know according to the Council on Foreign
Relations the West is now free of
conflict not including the drug war to
quote human progress org no person alive
can remember our western hemisphere to
be as peaceful as it is today and that's
amazing so what do you say Democrats in
media that is a great direction why not
keep it going
all right one why can't you just admit
it works when we shake hands and move on
to the next segment you know let's have
fun in the neighborhood and let's just
not talk politics let's shut up because
I'm doing I was wondering when you were
showing the clips Greg I thought you
know it's pretty clear he manufactured
this view I mean you know yeah he did
okay and then it seems to me he says
without getting Mexico to agree that
they're going to keep the asylum people
right he says all we got a deal and
there's some secret to it then the
Mexicans come and say oh no no secret so
at some point I think maybe Greg saying
something I'm not seeing
I hope this is not just you know sort of
tribal I back Trump you don't but I mean
I just don't see that there's anything
that Mexico conceded so in a way it
looks like Trump got rolld Jesse I
strongly disagree with that one because
they agreed to send 500 troops to their
site only Birbal 8,000 troops to the
southern border and they're gonna
Institute the Mexico protocols which
says if you're seeking asylum you stay
in Mexico and that's good and that's
progress want and the media has lied
about this because they want to try to
sabotage any victory he has if there's
no new deal then why'd the President of
Mexico say we have a new deal on
Saturday because he gets it doesn't make
any sense so we shouldn't have to
negotiate with a foreign power in order
to fix her immigration system but the
Democrats have left us no choice
Nancy Pelosi could solve the asylum grab
in a heartbeat but she doesn't because
she wants to secure political power
instead of securing the country the Dems
like to call this bullying how is
flexing American economic muscle to get
what you want bullying that's just
America first and the Democrats don't
like that and usually the media when
there's a deal like we've seen NAFTA or
Paris or Iran or Bergdahl they praise
these bad deals and and every time we
lose money we lose power and we lose
face but this is a great deal in the
media they don't like it because it's
good for America yo Dana I there is this
argument that oh but they already agreed
to it but they I think that the tariffs
pushed them faster to the agreement I
think that's what the threat got them on
board
initially right now I was also kind of
kicking myself cuz Kirsten Nielsen the
secretary the former secretary who was
fired resigned you know back then she
had actually in January she had
orchestrated this deal with the Mexicans
in order to send the National Guard
troops and a keep make them keep more of
people in Mexico and maybe the the
details weren't finalized whatever I
find it hard to imagine that the
president was actually ever gonna go
forward with 25% tariffs but in a
heading into an election year when the
economy is the strongest point of view
but I think there might be some five
what is it called three-dimensional
underwater chests going on yes because
you know what's happened what Democrats
are now saying tariffs are bad yeah I
know
crabs are saying wait tariffs are a tax
on consumers yes and businesses and this
is wrong
and we can't have that and I think Wow
now we've really got them yeah we flip
the script
alright diggin you are the
businessperson here I I was thinking
that maybe this that Trump sees Trump I
don't think is into war I think he's
kind of yeah I think he from a financial
standpoint he thinks it's a waste of
blood treasure and just in time I think
he sees trade wars as the replacement
for war and why should I I mean should
that
isn't that progress why I will choose
tariffs over violence yes anyway I think
any of us would make that but there has
to be some middle ground and I will put
on my terror face which is yeah my
terror face yeah what he's doing is
because he uses these taxes these border
taxes to push back on Mexico and then
leaves them up in the air like you know
what if you don't play ball I'm bringing
them back that does create a lot of
business uncertainty about investment
and growth you have manufacturing in
this country looking really soft this
year and businesses dear General Motors
3m are pulling back on investment
they're not hiring they're even
potentially laying off people so it
introduces that uncertainty he's called
himself tariff man and you have to take
him at his word he likes using tariffs I
think about it like a preteen boy using
nunchucks yeah where he's whacking him
and he gets you to back up initially but
then he eventually
smacks himself in the face potentially
that's that's maybe where this goes he
needs to focus on the economy could hurt
yeah but you might on the other hand you
might see China go well he really means
it and this is I mean this could be
progress speaking of progress
I passed my driver's test I only got one
thing wrong I I didn't see her crossing
the street no III did I scored perfectly
except for one thing did he give you a
gold star on your chart no but they were
I want to I want to do a shout-out to
Don Scardino who was my little
instructor who drove me around the city
what was the one thing he nailed you on
oh he wasn't he was the instructor but
then they have the tester what happened
what is there was a street that was you
had to do a complete stop on but there
was a street coming down here from a
side that was weird so I want there was
cars so I wanted to like get out a
little further and you're not supposed
to get out a little further because
you're too short to see over you know
that wasn't necessary you should let me
bask in my moment okay sorry
congratulations no you're just like
Bernie and the rest picture turnout on
your driver's license a little older
than my last one oh we gotta find that
we gotta find it's his live TV so this
is my address on it when you take the
disguise
exactly there I am it's my beautiful
fingers producer just said I look creepy
I just want to see okay what is it safe
for the height let's keep that like you
know why it's private this is over I'm
not here every day I'm saying nothing
yeah there's a mistake on mine oh oh
that's right because I sort of it did
they
there's a typo that's pretty funny okay
guy told you about my photos how long
does it last
I don't know is it five years ten oh
that's great that's good can't wait to
drive I gotta get my I gotta get that
phone book out yeah I gotta wear glasses